jedes element in diesem universum
besteht aus denselben grundbausteinen
protonen neutronen und elektronen nur
ihre anzahl bestimmt die eigenschaften
des elements das gold zum beispiel gelb
ist glänzt und relativ leicht verformbar
ist liegt an seinen 79 protonen im kern
aber fügt man einem goldatome nur ein
proton hinzu dann erhält man ein völlig
neues element quecksilber das einzige
metall das bei standardbedingungen also
bei null grad celsius und ein bar druck
flüssig ist im periodensystem der
elemente finden sich alle uns bisher
bekannten elemente wieder genau geordnet
nach der ordnungszahl diese zeigt an wie
viele protonen das element in seinem
kern hat das periodensystem wurde 1869
beinahe zeitgleich sowohl von einem
deutschen notar meyer und einem russen
dimitri mittel entwickelt wendeler es
ist heutzutage allerdings bekannt da er
mit seinem periodensystem elemente und
ihre eigenschaften vorhersagen konnte
obwohl diese damals noch gar nicht
entdeckt wurden elemente die
untereinander in einer gruppe stehen
verhalten sich nämlich oft ähnlich die
edelgase in der letzten gruppe reagieren
zum beispiel alle fast gar nicht mit
anderen stoffen
während die alkali metalle niedrige
dichten haben und heftig mit wasserstoff
und sauerstoff reagieren aber das
periodensystem ist selbst heute 150
jahre später noch nicht abgeschlossen
es werden weiterhin neue elemente mit
immer mehr protonen erzeugt und damit
entdeckt je weiter wir im periodensystem
nach rechts und nach unten wandern desto
schwerer werden die elemente und desto
höher ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
das element radioaktiv ist und wieder
zerfällt das kann man sich vorstellen
wie den bau von häusern
je mehr protonen in den kern gepackt
werden je größer man also die häuser
baut desto instabiler werden sie und
desto höher ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass sie zusammenbrechen
das ist radioaktivität interessant ist
auch die zeit in der die atome zerfallen
manche radioaktiven elemente zerfallen
in bruchteilen einer sekunde andere zu
fallen erst nach millionen von jahren
wenn man zb einen klumpen uran 233 in
der hand hält und dann 159 1200 jahre
wartet dann ist die hälfte der atome in
diesem klumpen zerfallen uran 233 hat
dementsprechend eine halbwertszeit von
159.000 200 jahren und diese
halbwertszeit der elemente wird
tendenziell immer kürzer je schwerer die
elemente werden unter anderem aus diesem
grund hatte noch nie ein mensch einen
klumpen moskau wie um in der hand
gehalten das element wurde 2003 zum
ersten mal erschaffen und hat eine
halbwertszeit von nur 0,65 sekunden
hätte man einen kunden davon in der hand
würde es in nur wenigen augenblicken in
leichtere elemente zerfallen elemente
wie moskau juni um und novelli um findet
man deswegen auch nicht in der natur
sondern muss sich aufwändig in
teilchenbeschleunigern erzeugen bringt
es also gar nichts immer weitere
elemente mit immer mehr protonen zu
erzeugen da sie sowieso quasi sofort
wieder zerfallen würden nun verschiedene
berechnungen und modelle sagen voraus
dass es in diesem see der instabilen
atome eine insel der stabilität gibt ein
kleiner bereich in dem atome genau die
richtige anzahl an protonen und
neutronen haben um nicht sofort wieder
zerfallen
hier könnten sich neue stabile elemente
verbergen die wir so in der natur noch
nicht gefunden haben
welche eigenschaften sie haben und ob
sie eine echten welt anwendung finden
können das versuchen forscher gerade
herauszufinden
[Musik]
dieses video hier ist in zusammenarbeit
mit dem pm magazin entstanden in der
titelgeschichte der aktuellen ausgabe
geht es um genau dieses thema und ich
habe für mein video ein paar exklusive
einblicke bekommen für euch bringt aber
nicht nur ein besseres video raus
sondern auch ein gewinnspiel einer von
euch kann nämlich das größte lego set
aller zeiten gewinnen den millennium
falcon aus star wars
wie das geht das erfahrt ihr am ende des
videos
was entscheidet darüber ob ein element
stabil ist oder nicht
aus dem chemieunterricht weiß man dass
elektronen in höhlen angeordnet sind
atome wollen diese möglichst voll machen
deswegen gehen manche atome wie natrium
und chlorid verbindungen ein und
tauschen elektronen miteinander aus
andere wie zum beispiel aragon und xenon
reagieren überhaupt nicht denn sie haben
als ewiger so schon die richtige anzahl
von elektronen in ihrer äußersten hülle
nun ein ähnliches prinzip gilt auch im
atomkern sowohl protonen als auch
neutronen ordnen sich in bestimmten
höhen an und bei einer ganz bestimmten
anzahl von protonen oder neutronen in
der sogenannten magischen zahl sind sie
stabil
der pm autor martin schlak hat das in
seinem artikel zu superschweren
elementen besonders anschaulich erklärt
ist ein umzugswagen bis zum rand mit
paketen voll gepackt dann fallen die
pakete nicht um sie geben sich
gegenseitig halt weil der wagen genau
richtig gefüllt ist die zahl der
protonen bei einem element ist
festgelegt gold hat zum beispiel immer
79 protonen im kern aber die zahl der
neutronen lässt sich variieren normales
gold wie wir es kennen hat 118 neutronen
es gibt aber auch gold mit 116 oder
sogar nur 97 neutronen diese
verschiedenen varianten desselben
elements heißen isotope und sind im fall
von gold leider alle instabil und
radioaktiv das hängt wiederum damit
zusammen dass sich die form des
atomkerns mit der anzahl der protonen
und neutronen verändert
man glaubt es kaum aber selbst im femto
mieter bereich ist nicht alles
punktförmig viele atomkerne im unteren
rechten bereich des periodensystems sind
zum beispiel eher lang gezogen wie ein
football
das kann dafür sorgen dass sie instabil
sind und zerfallen stabiler sind
hingegen atomkerne die wie eine kugel
geformt sind 114 protonen und 184
neutronen dort könnte die insel der
stabilität liegen denn dort ist der
atomkern kugelförmig zumindest nach
aktuellen berechnungen und simulationen
das atom dass genau diese anzahl an
protonen und neutronen hat heisst levi
um 298 denn 114 protonen plus 184
neutronen ergibt 298 es wurde noch nicht
hergestellt aber physiker glauben es
könnte genau in der mitte der insel der
stabilität liegen
es wäre quasi doppelt magisch weil
sowohl die protonen als auch die
neutronen ihre jeweiligen hüllen genau
ausfüllen je nachdem wie man fragt
könnte es aber auch copernicium 291 oder
293 sein und es muss auch nicht ein
element alleine sein dass länger stabil
bleibt die theorie sagt voraus dass es
eher ein bereich ist eben eine insel in
dem sich mehrere atome und ihre isotope
befinden können und alle profitieren von
der nähe zu den magischen zahlen
experimentell kann man das jetzt schon
zeigen 4 und 289 hat eine halbwertszeit
von 1,9 sekunden mit nur einem neutron
mehr das wäre dann für opium 290 kann
man schon eine halbwertzeit von 19
sekunden erwarten eine schiere
unendlichkeit dafür dass das element so
schwer ist die halbwertzeiten werden
also länger je mehr wir der insel der
stabilität kommen wissenschaftler
spekulieren gerne darüber wie lange flur
wie um 298 stabil bleiben wird
die schätzungen liegen zwischen wenigen
minuten und millionen von jahren sollte
das element wirklich von dauer sein dann
hätte das potenziell unglaubliche folgen
das wäre das erste superschwere element
das wir wirklich chemisch untersuchen
können mit dem wir experimente anstellen
und dass wir auf seine eigenschaften
testen könnten wer weiß welche
möglichkeiten uns ein komplett neues
element eröffnet es könnte ein extrem
guter stromleiter sein oder besondere
magnetische eigenschaften besitzen
vielleicht ist es auch etwas gut dass
wir uns heute noch gar nicht vorstellen
können
aber so weit sind wir heute noch nicht
denn bisher wurde noch kein einziges
super schweres atom auf der insel der
stabilität erzeugt das liegt vor allem
daran dass es ein unglaublich
schwieriger und langwieriger prozess ist
superschwere elemente zu erzeugen
das macht man nämlich in dem man gerne
miteinander fusioniert aus einem kalzium
atome 20 und einem blei atom mit 82
protonen entsteht zum beispiel ein neues
element mit 102 protonen jubiläum
um diese fusion zu ermöglichen muss man
allerdings energie aufwenden
denn zwei positiv geladene atomkerne
stoßen sich elektrisch voneinander ab
erst wenn sie mit genügend energie
aufeinander stoßen wird die abstoßende
elektrische kraft überschritten und die
starke kernkraft hält die protonen und
neutronen im neu entstandenen kern
zusammen in einem teilchenbeschleuniger
wie diesem hier in darmstadt wird genau
das gemacht je schwerer die atome sind
die man miteinander fusionieren möchte
desto mehr energie muss man auch
aufwenden was bedeutet dass die
geschwindigkeit der kollision erhöht
werden muss in darmstadt erreichen die
atome bis zu einem zehntel der
lichtgeschwindigkeit bevor sie
aufeinanderprallen
wenn dann nach vielen versuchen endlich
ein einzelnes medium atom entstanden ist
dann muss es schnell gehen
je nach isotop haben die forscher nicht
einmal die dauer eines wimpernschlag
zeit um die eigenschaften des gerade neu
entstandenen elements zu untersuchen
die wichtigste frage ist aktuell ob sich
das 114 element er wie ein edelgas oder
wie ein schwermetall verhält im
periodensystem steht für opium
unterbleibt
deswegen müsste es eigentlich die
eigenschaften eines schwermetalls haben
aber bisherige forschungsergebnisse
geben hinweise darauf dass er sich auch
anders verhalten könnte auf das ergebnis
dieser tests wird schon mit spannung
gewartet denn es steht einiges auf dem
spiel sollte man herausfinden dass sich
das element anders verhält als die logik
des periodensystems vorhersagt dann wäre
das unglaublich die superschwere
elemente könnten ganz unerwartete
eigenschaften zeigen und das
periodensystem der elemente könnte dann
nur noch das system der elemente heißen
theoretisch gibt es übrigens noch zwei
weitere inseln der stabilität und zwar
bei 126 und bei 164 protonen beide
elemente wurden noch nie erschaffen
element nummer 126 heißt um die hexe um
das ist allerdings nur ein vorläufiger
name bis seine ersten erschaffer der
international union of pure and applied
chemistry
den vorschlag für den dauerhaften namen
machen dürfen einstein juni um und
moskau wurden alle auf diese art und
weise genannt
die hoffnung auf ein doktor rossi um ist
also noch nicht ganz gestorben
das pm magazin veranstaltet ein
gewinnspiel bei dem ihr einen lego
millennium falcon gewinnen könnte
zusätzlich zu der chance auf diesen
hauptgewinn bekommt jeder teilnehmer der
möchte zwei gratis ausgaben des pm
magazins inklusive der aktuellen ausgabe
wenn ihr also noch mehr über
superschwere elemente erfahren wollt
dann könnt ihr euch die titelgeschichte
der neuen pm durchlesen
da gibt es noch mehr infos details und
interviews mit forschern zum thema und
auch der rest der ausgabe ist wie immer
gefüllt mit spannenden themen
die nasa hat zum beispiel einen
neuartigen kernreaktor entwickelt mit
dem sie das sonnensystem erkunden will
fische werden per laser von parasiten
befreit und es gibt jetzt eine
umweltfreundliche verpackung aus pilzen
den link zum gewinnspiel und die
teilnahmebedingungen findet ihr wie
immer unten in der video beschreibung
vielen dank fürs zuschauer und wie immer
bleibt neugierig
[Musik]